[Musique]
j'ai mon pays
tous
m
à
chez eux
non
chan
quand on va fouiller dans nos archives
ici à radio canada ces genres de choses
qu'on retrouve lorsqu on écrit le nom
céline dion c'est une céline dion à la
mode 2009 82 est ce qu'on vous présente
aujourd'hui pour le 50e anniversaire de
naissance de ces mondiaux ce soir ce
sont les trois plus anciennes archives
de céline dion qu'on a retrouvés dans
nos votes alors ce qu'on vient de voir
se dérouler en février 1980 2 c'est la
troisième plus ancien archives de céline
dion dans le coffre-fort à radio canada
elle participait à l'émission allô
boubou animée par jacques boulanger
c'est une émission spéciale pour
l'animateur qui marquait la centième de
son émission allô boubou qui est
terminée 110 ans céline dion tu iras
loin la deuxième présence énergique de
céline dion
c'était en décembre 1980 heures alors à
ce moment-là et venait de lancer
quelques semaines plus tôt deux albums
ses deux premiers albums simultanément
son premier album la voix du bon dieu et
son deuxième album un album de noël
elle prenait pas une spéciale de noël
sont nous ont diffusé le 25 décembre
animé par serge laprade et l'a choisi de
chanter de la voix du bon dieu
[Musique]
que
non
chanteur
elle était bien entourée pour cette
prestation là donc en décembre 1980 est
maintenant la plus vieille archive de
céline dion qu'on a retrouvés dans nos
coffres
ça a été diffusé en octobre 1981 heures
elle participait à une émission animée
par donald lautrec
c'était donc avant la parution de ses
premiers albums mais déjà elle avait un
succès ce n'était qu'un rêve
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
blessures
dans chaque main
des pavillons bleus
k
[Musique]
et on sait plaisir avec une dernière
archives puisque on si céline dion a
chanté pour le pape jean paul ii au
stade olympique en septembre 1984 me l
avait déjà avancé chanter au stade
olympique
l'année précédente les hymnes nationaux
avant un match de baseball les expos de
montréal dont tim raines et à la gary
carter était là et céline dion elle
accordé une entrevue à pierre dufau
jeunes amateurs de blues man oui j'adore
le bis par via les icones mans un petit
peu mais chez eux les explosions venir
du projet
justement garder ma peur de votre
soit affectée par le froid pour ses pas
chaud aussi non c'est pas chauvin comme
foyer chez fayard del zotto de ma gorge
fait de même devant le grand inconnu en
début d'émission au céline que vous avez
un grand succès que c'est bien vendu 250
et is de cette chanson d'amour et
d'amitié
est-ce que
pensez au moment de leur registre et que
ce serait si grand succès pas du tout
moi j'espère toujours le présentement ça
fonctionne très bien prospère de côté
gauche et touchait du bois et à contenir
une semaine tout jeune actuellement il à
s en aller en france pour leur présenter
d'amour ou d'amitié